la renaissance des vélos dilecta c'est
l'aboutissement d'une alchimie entre le
fabricant tourangeau de cycle sifac est
le fils d'un ancien coureur
professionnel de l'équipe dilecta une
marque créée il ya plus d'un siècle dans
le berry
plus précisément au blanc dans l'indre
direct a été créée en 1913 et on a une
photo de lusine en 1921 dont qui était
déjà élargi plus de 150 personnes à
l'époque la production de 10 les cta a
connu son apogée dans les années 1936 37
avec plus de 25 mille vélos fabriqués il
y avait jusqu'à 250 personnes et c'est
une véritable saga industrielle pour la
région puisque c'était vraiment direct a
été le fleuron de la région et puis
aussi une formidable aventure humaine
alors on a ici le maillot de l'équipe
dilecta wolber l'épopée directeur
wolberg le maillot aux couleurs origines
d'origine de la marque
et puis bah ce lien familial et et
affectif que j'ai c'est effectivement
puisque mon père a fait partie de cette
équipe en 1966 avec andré darrigade et
et le bauhb et c'est ce qui m'a amené
effectivement à m'attacher à relancer la
marque dire et à l'entreprise sifa qui
construit des vélos en indre et loire
depuis 40 ans et donc l'opérateur du
retour de dix lecteurs
ce choix ne doit rien au hasard une
éthique commune a rapproché les deux
partenaires
un cycliste qui va venir chercher un
cadre artisanal fabriqué en france est
fabriqué en centre val de loire comme
chez sifac va venir finalement chercher
une histoire du local est derrière tout
ça y est des valeurs éthiques et je
pense que à travers ce partenariat avec
dilecta je pense que l'histoire de
dilecta qu est très attaché à la région
une histoire de sifac aussi qui est très
attaché à la région ça fait 40 ans qu'on
est basé en région 122 loire fait que
finalement il était évident que les deux
histoires se rencontrent
vous remarquerez également qu'on a
privilégié les composants français
locaux avec des pneumatiques hutchinson
dons qui sont fabriqués à montargis est
également bien sûr une guidoline
française est bidon porte bidon de notre
partenaire et fall qui est basée à
jargeau à côté d'orléans pour parfaire
ce pur produit du centre val de loire le
nom de sa ville d'origine lui a été
donné leblanc qui prévoit d'ouvrir en
2022 un musée dédié à l'histoire de dix
lecteurs